good morning guess we can get started
welcome to the panel covering descents
in comparative perspective my name is
Amon Carter Allen I'll be moderating
today I have to say I'm really humbled
and honored to be presenting such an
accomplished group of people between the
three of them we have a Nobel Prize
winner a pulitzer winner and a winner of
the international press freedom award
and so i'm trying very hard not to feel
intimidated as i pose questions to them
with such an impressive trio I'm going
to limit my remarks as much as possible
right now and and also later on because
I would guess that if there's anything I
have to say they can probably say it
better than me and I also want to make
sure that the audience has a chance to
plenty of time to interact and ask
questions after we get done with initial
remarks in a panel discussion so let me
briefly move on to introductions um so
my left I have Nadira is I Ava she's a
Russian journalist who has been
internationally recognized for her
reporting on security issues in the
North Caucasus from 2007 to 2011 she was
editor-in-chief of the weekly newspaper
chernova I hope I'm saying that right
which means the draft in Dagestan and
the newspaper has been described by
reporters without borders as dog astons
leading independent newspaper and then
from 2008 to 2011 she and four
colleagues from the newspaper were
placed under investigation and accused
of exciting hatred against law
enforcement authorities and while they
wanted trial the authorities changed
their tactics tactics and pressured her
to step down her reporting and
prosecution have drawn the attention of
numerous press and press freedom
organizations and that its royal Board
of the Washington Post has praised her
work calling her quote a first-rate
journalist and a hero she was a
recipient of a international press
freedom award in 2010 for risking her
freedom and security for her reporting
and she is currently a visiting scholar
at the Harriman Institute here at
Columbia far under the table we have
Clifford Jay Levy who was named deputy
deputy editor of the New York Times
Metro section in March
of 2011 previously he was based in Mott
at the Moscow Bureau of the new york
times most recently as a bureau chief he
joined the bureau as Moscow
correspondent in july two thousand six
and had been a special projects reporter
for the Metro desk previously since 2000
before joining the Metro desk he served
as chief of the papers Alba Nibiru and
as a political reporter City Hall
correspondent and a Newark correspondent
he joined the times in 1990 as a
political reporter sorry as a new
assistant and was promoted to report her
in 1992 and before coming to the times
he was a reporter for The New York
bureau of United Press International mr.
levy won the 2003 Pulitzer Prize for
Investigative Reporting for a three-part
series that exposed the sometimes fatal
neglect of mentally ill people in a
privately-run adult homes regulated by
New York State he also received the
george polk award for the series in 1998
he won a polka ward for articles on the
campaign finance practices of prominent
state officials in New York and in 2009
mr. levy was an international print
winner for the rfk journalism awards for
Kremlin rules a series about how
Russia's leaders have eroded democracy
and human rights the Society of
Professional Journalists awarded mr.
levy the 2008 sigma delta chi award for
foreign correspondents for the series
and he also won a 2009 epi award in the
category of Best web special feature
enterprise and he won a third Georgia
polka ward in 2010 for above the law a
series about corruption and abuse of
power in Russia two decades after the
collapse of communism I encourage you to
check out his impressive work on the new
york times website Joseph E stiglitz was
born in Gary Indiana in 1943 and he's a
graduate of Amherst College he received
his PhD from MIT in 1967 and became a
full professor at Yale in 1970 he was 27
years old and in nineteen seven 1979 was
awarded the John Bates Clark award which
is given by any leads
by the American Economic Association to
the Economist under 40 who has made the
most significant contribution to the
field he's taught at Princeton Stanford
MIT and was a Drummond professor in a
fellow of all souls college at Oxford
and he is now university professor at
Columbia University in New York and
co-chair of Columbia University's
Committee on global thought and he's
also co-founder and co-president of the
initiative for policy dialogue here at
Columbia in 2001 he was awarded the
nobel prize in economics for his
analyses of markets with asymmetric
information and he was also a lead
author of the 1995 report on the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change which shared the 2007 Nobel Peace
Prize in 2011 time magazine named him
one of the 100 most influential
influential people in the world so now
that I'm done reading off this
impressive list of awards we can move on
to the discussion and as you know this
panel is part of a conference sponsored
by Columbia's Harriman Institute and
it's one of several events commemorating
the collapse of the Soviet Union and the
end of the Cold War the broader theme of
this pan this conference is is the Cold
War over Russia and US media from
perestroika to the twenty twelve
elections and so I know today that when
we're talking about covering descent
will be talking a lot about questions
like whether the Cold War past
contributes to continues to influence
media in Russia or whether we're looking
at a completely new media landscape
there and that is engaging dissent in
new ways but will also get into what the
what challenges journalists are facing
in Russia today whether these are
different or the same as as what they've
experienced in the past but I also hope
that we can zoom out of the the Russia
discussion to talk more broadly about
covering dissent in the world today in
the context of of new media and
especially because last year was such a
banner year for dissent from Cairo to
Moscow to Athens and even its wall
street here in new york city and i think
as we hear about the examples of
covering dissent in russia will will
will be a very fascinating and
instructive jumping-off place for
kind of a broader discussion about what
it means to cover dissent in the world
today and I hope we can get into
questions of where the line is between
between activism and reporting and
whether that line I think sometimes it's
in the American context it's taken for
granted that that line should exist in
other countries it may not be so and it
may actually be changing here too and so
I hope we can talk about what some of
the hazards and the opportunities of
blurring that line are and also what
some of the successes and failures of
media and covering dissent have been in
the last year in Russia but also in
other countries but let's definitely
start with Russia it's a perfect
jumping-off point I would like to pass
the the microphone over to miss I Ava
who will talk about her experiences and
connect some of the dots for us so thank
you thank you thank you
daca vrei via Greenwich in a penalty to
monotony of approach Enya option me yeah
we'll get her a microphone we can record
it in the middle we'll have to move
right why don't you snap he's just we
cannot it's okay to be there all in a
fix that's it um unfortunately my time
is limited i only have 15 minutes to
talk and the subject I would like to
cover is very broad yeah residue service
to play me a nadie chest I would like to
divide my presentation in two parts el
muchacho pasadena' pasadena city sauce
me daghestani at who the young dro booty
so i would like to dedicate the first
part to the situation with mass media in
Dagestan i'm from the guys knock off
that are in the caucuses in the northern
caucasus in particular if not reach a
good position at a MOOC artistic price
Rajesh Yves Rossy Karoly roots tiempo
price hood knockoff guys and thank you
and the second part of my presentation
is about you know the unbalance between
the protests in moscow in Russia and
with what happens in Dagestan know
madera true superstar ella y deja tu e
SI todo su Couture appreciative asana is
gadget epsilon cattleya was gonna latch
the wood and the moderator of panel
discussion has already represented the
knee and the newspaper and I worked for
44 years being meets editor-in-chief
vital national screams contacts factor
she's not suitable de cabra treaties
Chechen estado de bois will be to chile
de la gazzetta so i will begin with the
with effects on december 16th 2011 the
founder of the newspaper
kamala Hadji Murat Kemal was killed he
etobi so another estetica a new kotaku
xavier high shoes a five-year saga sure
she ate up still a Serie liquid at the
Institute of abuddin oppressive severe
cough cough cough I scuba Kakashi this
killing should be viewed as the final
known drop which ruined the mass media
free mass media in the northern caucasus
irani as horny process practically price
Heidi merely mr. Wimbush a tiff Chechnya
kabardino-balkaria similar cases can be
remembered you know that happened in
Chechnya in Gujarati and
kabardino-balkaria see chassis anemia
due in pharma sony against recruit
lyricist kim is Donald negatory stays in
a pre substitute for gionee so and i
don't mean you know the branches are
like a offices of big information
agencies but more like you know local
newspaper is a tree root of a prcis
instituting and Jay I want to talk
about mass media about press as an
institution yaki movers emotional
collage to read you on Syria Kafkaesque
now Adina's nebula to street in la raza
spell i co-own ostensible scars and talk
biz informatin epocrates ish in the
region this the northern caucasus which
is one of the most sensitive regions for
the moscow power power in Moscow is left
without any coverage and informational
coverage by mass media Italians with
Socastee pin you priests Austria CD
smirnova produced a figural hace la voz
doctor is a treasonous pastrami Nia
nerve
any part of chula vehicle so this is the
region where the excessive numbers of
law enforcement federal law enforcement
are concentrated and this is the region
where the civil rights human rights are
violated and grossly 30 on switching
schools instructor a conflict a rocket
or mrs. Guarini abuddin so this is the
region with a very complex structure of
conflict and I don't have time like to
cover it now by the Macho strae
periodic damu connect on moves a
discussion tuck I've not seen you dial
kavkaza could Kafkaesque cough cough
cough Vaseline easier Kafkaesque hi
Republican Committee in camera system he
thought it's now booted a practice to a
massive receipt Kafkaesque problematic
so that's why I would like you know to
tackle more the question of unbalanced
protists so to speak you know then how
the population of the Northern Caucasus
views the protests in Moscow and how
they react to them practice namitha
races cos no necesitas parties parties
namitha opposite salimos colonist estate
Sookie Easter Christie Frogley Tijuana
speaking about the protesters in Moscow
and I would like you know to emphasize
that you know you can divide them into
three parts ah at nine chest namaz learn
a bully d is puzzled neta not so
nihilistic one part of it which is
always ready to to act in the very
effective are Russian nationalists star
h st t dmocratique a liberal so the
second part is the Liberal Democratic
wing III discussion touch a sauna but a
muslin a selenium Wilson approaches no
imprint a teeny Midkiff to achieve in
apology
and sorry and the third part is the you
know great numbers of people who joined
in the protests but they don't have any
political views or and ideas you know
they advocate yes Liberace live Nemanja
8am ah salud e stata is bigoted Kakuta
nepali teacher scoffs took to the
Romania so this is a great number of
people I've just mentioned you know they
try to stay away from any political
issues annouced arises be glad to
discuss on taco give the lead your
separate budget evening and they don't
have any preference as far as leadership
of this movement is concerned tipperary
liberality mock ratito sketches
anonymous glad no poker game is Owen and
in my opinion the Liberal Democratic
part of the protesters are very poorly
organized Tomatina is probably melody
hora de alla Jerusha so they have the
problem you know Clara's all there are
the absence of them you know who could
consolidate them achieve in a problem is
eg in a plot for me they obviously don't
have a strong and ideological platform
Chuck minimum takushi para my and they
don't have a well-defined program
Thibodeau knots analista now hear words
about nationalists actually no stove
right here scars on tuck of Leon E ed
not families messages destitution ah
shoosh shoosh astina it seems that the
influence of the ideas advocated by
nationalists is a very significant very
strong igniter already warned you move
move
nikto is scarce on technique akiza's
politicians conspiracy so none of the
forces in the political spectrum Russia
can't ignore them original story not on
a list of jihad ap premier minus Rho
President Putin EDA's prestel Italy
vaquita le preste Attila libera Nova
krula and so you know Putin and his
government as well as some
representative of the Liberal Democratic
Movement feel you know they've been
radiated to the Nationalists good night
Adam Scott intact phony Ojinaga
journalist improvisation nick is nice
you stole Louise kavkaza privately
chat activity gross dance capacities of
the Utah pros but you Mook of cars
depreciating admitting contract system
so and against this background
journalists and many activists in the
civil rights movement ask a question why
the caucuses the Northern Caucasus
doesn't join in the protests namaz glad
at 0 by Virginia and pathogenic of
Castle ocean pragmatist in my opinion
the behavior of the Caucasus is very
pragmatic twist in naga naga rostislav
cassia tonka kanagawa so do please
purchase to see a massive ish low
profile cific are too good are both just
a few words about the caucuses and how
the election will carried out there they
strike a majority of people refuse to
vote because they were against the
falsification of the election every
bottle goes do mo voy para presidenta
rossi and the elections to the state
duma elections the presidential election
subrosa gah Sudarsan adam was madly
understood of races kampala teachers
comp ostrosky cocking student so and
another question does the State Duma has
any significance in the political scene
in Russia not wit bomb on my TV didn't
let you tow car shows mattresses go
specific oh so the answer is obvious for
those who knows the political scenario
says of today sorry it's doneski la vela
previews arisa kanno Lu Jia Jia
Kafkaesque Harris public osnabrck sheet
or toady kibriya but one any printed be
at least noon and the fact that like
almost you know zero percent of people
showed up at the voting stations in the
caucuses in the northern caucasus is an
answer to that question and they can be
explained yes Louie private utility turn
the test is a prostitution swells not
with mahadji live in Abu Baara and his
cousin Mia Hadiya na boo better wash is
not home yet ideally novel butters knock
on my varsity so every time you ask
somebody like you know you know did you
vote and we ask somebody who knows
somebody will know somebody else you
know did you vote and then the answer
will be no la presidencia barack's
possible anymore it could work it was as
the situation was slightly different the
presidential election at leeches
officials to install a spiritual e at a
balanced Esprit muchas tonight Abuja
Nikki go sushi Prost of the Bravo la
prima de la parte privily warnham so
during the presidential elections voters
were forced to vote and they were
predominantly government employees and
public sector workers immediately the
policy neva she'd almost done yet does
it change anything I don't think this is
aa doom Estonia te e
satria stina tip a truck over pros toe
khakis got his beer at sag lavar is
clicking so consequently another
question arises you know how is the head
of the Republic elected unless my chair
the president of Ronnie well he is
appointed by the President of Russia
though sadly it's not graph Denis it is
public key if any Brava we'll be right
so I vote Lydia so consequently the
populations like the citizens of the
Republic deprived of the right to elect
the head of the state of the Republic
the Anna formally meet probably potato
costume officially they have a right to
elect delegates to the State Duma but it
doesn't change anything okok oh yeah
true para presidenta was not a strong
Nina and how the presidential elections
are carried out you you know you know
without me oh hi sneaker Cheetos I could
go just which will bar across the bay
smoothly and not the situation is that
when it is absolutely senseless and
useless to participate in the election
so it's not just admitting approaching
what you have about of totoro to falsify
cut it or abuse with him so that's why
to participate in the rallies to protest
you know this situation is also doesn't
also doesn't have any sense hadaba more
ET para testified profile sivakasi known
is above a toast opravila ustinov Leonie
godwin godwin appreciate ality gossip
rag lost on of leaning restriction
domestic jerusha's accommodated so
falsification to protest against the
falsification of the elections is
absolutely you know futile because the
the rules are set no matter what you
doing how you you know vote there is
certainly no set of rules that are
followed in the election and there are
limitations
d estar al Assad no Esther and abyss
smoothly noches at Yogi Berra this he
grabbed by a problem most of couture oh
oh soooo de cotorra the day UT nuit so
the one and it is absolutely useless to
play the games the terms of which are
imposed on you by somebody else the rest
are another prosa would even ask a
thumbtack name Selenia what I could not
sign a lease teaches character not on a
patella teaches eff not alone it does
Chevy nice teaches keha ruto
miscellaneous contact us cosas para
teachers can resist contrast rusty this
is an ideal weight cafcass of children
coming would wait and politics couple
certain the situation with the with
nationalistic patriotism chauvinism in
russia and everything there is a
popularized in that sense makes the
citizens of Republic's and the northern
caucasus and outsiders yahuh goose
Gossage to print EP miss kiev in a
salinity Easter with unica forma de
Santa in the camellia so long as they
are so very low percentage of voters is
the manifestation of the oak descent so
to speak if principal Ozma chestunna
Selenia Sushruta azada Navajo Pola so
that that means that the population of
these Republic's is outside you know the
frames of the setup legitimate field
night on phone a lob lob falsification
couture / diodes top returnee resulted
amina key statistics is key official a
statistic coverage to amina silikov
cascade is public they used aveeno step
et tu quien est presente result
yorkie presidenta strongly so but if we
look at the numbers officially published
number is a we will see that the
official numbers show that ninety-five
percent of the voters in the republics
of northern caucasus vote at a price
Hoda snippet amuto kavkaza perceiving
the politicking i think is no more glad
for mevoli ruling I don't worry not
present in here and nikolas aoudi a
fatality see official statistics is did
95% whoa but in fact you know less than
five percent work caustic dolly dutiful
paducah its accuracy da otha timely
percent so official numbers are always
the canoga the caucus is always in the
first rings no realistic avast led
prostate Larry ruled Institute we borrow
but in reality when people simply ignore
the Institute of Elections principe does
not share to Paul Ignazio do my absolute
increasingly getting misty my sister
wasted so this is the evidence of the
crisis of any legitimate you know
existence of the Soviet power of the
Russian powers already know he's so good
in the conferences so they did they
basically like in the minds of people
they don't exist haja graffiti on
meeting Gil daghestani knock off cos
pahlavi locket officially no poslednie
meeting casaste haces an edgy Sydney do
appear of emitting gamma sketchy trataba
de cabra if we won't produce this pretty
louis Astana silico so but rarely do
happen in the southern Caucasus one of
them happened ten days before the first
rail in moscow in december forth and it
was the rally to protest against the
abuses of power by the federal law
enforcement in that region organism
chinga a BC a leap of Tourette's
limiting gives uchino ee trainee
Estrella Bhavani paprikash in a bikini
episode machesney participants of the
rarely on a December fourth they
demanded that the federal enforcement
stopped to abduct the people and people
and execute them without trial and they
plan to repeat their process protests
you know now and then no meeting Guinea
apostoli escherichia pop retching EW
gross but protest rallies were not held
again and most likely because they were
threatened by the authorities you know
the pleasure would be taken against them
I'll act in your chest Nikita weekly
meeting over gay musical nosa mom Julie
at catalyst osmotic pressure genius
Sinha renew zero it's very meeting the
parties does not go swimming and
organizer is all of the rally in
Dagestan eventually refused to
synchronize directions with the protests
in Moscow the co-editor sous-vide
Strategos toe problem Attica station
agent the napa vs Kenya is this yup sure
I Siska on our Redeemer roughly chasm so
this is the evidence of the fact that
the problems faced with protesters in
Moscow and in Dagestan are different
yahuh choose a conscience service to
play in any Bastion takings about
Mickey's rodent and I would like to
close my presentation with a short
rather amusing episode not know Mesa
organization sobriety meeting of mass
crea a pseudo same approach of alternate
in forma parte esta sushi sushi rice tea
at one of the meetings of oil organizing
the protests in Moscow
they discussed the possibility of
alternative forms of protest against the
existing power it would blow preclude
inochi te mata de so this possibly they
discussed for methods I Nevius vidalista
Mustafa darwaja philosophy balls with
this toshiba he specialized they all
boil down to undermining the financial
security of the government etta zabrat
de is bank of a nice hip toss promotion
ago sadar Stanley so to pull all the
money from the banks which are mostly
all belong to the government Niebla
technology not to play Texas any Pilates
are common and apply to do and not to
pay rent and utilities if I you should
be supper moment nodular what you were
better yet and I think you ignore the
election day I'm not sure maybe wrong
the flow cheated them in year when it's
a when it was my turn to speak yah
govoru ah kavkaza oh not Savoy six
percent of economy kishi no acabo Brynja
tisha touch the wishes presented condom
50 nice at its new yoga voluto now long
gone we nip lighting so I've been when I
began to speak I reminded them that
eighty percent of the economy in the
caucuses in 80 80 is it like you know
the shader economy and we don't pay
taxes oh noz voice is a percent of
genius no bharata at a business
knowledge level so the eighty percent of
monetary circulation is in cash sup it's
numb we need the argentine you punko so
we don't keep our money in in banks
honest miss Kay's salmon at night
something Escape RAC said Aramis
commonality so we have one of the lowest
dinner in in Russia
payments for rent and utilities listen
and when you play so like we sometimes
we don't even pay them when you hold you
never better so we don't go to we don't
vote sadly astina kavkaza Domino's
repurchase toot so the inhabitants like
the population of these northern
caucasus have been protesting you know
for a long time by now on Bathsheba
thank you thank you so much so to move
the conversation along and maybe take a
bigger Russia bigger picture a Russia
perspective on the discussion I'd like
to invite mr. levy to to speak so I'm
going to keep my remarks relatively
brief I'm actually much more interested
in gauging in a Q&A in a conversation
here I'm interested in learning what
you're interested in learning about
especially given all the recent events
in Russia but one thing I do want to
discuss very briefly is the kind of the
nature of dissent in in the Russia of
Vladimir Putin and how that's different
than what we historically think of as
dissent in in the Soviet Union of the
former Soviet Union I spent five years
in Russia as a reporter for The New York
Times based in Moscow and one thing I
was continually surprised about when I
came back to the United States for a
visit was how people thought that the
Soviet Union still existed in as an idea
in practice in post-soviet Russia what I
mean by that is people were constant
thinking that there was a kind of a
brutal censorship that went on in Russia
that you could not criticize Putin at
all for example and that the kind of
practices that kind of KGB s practices
that existed for so many decades in the
Soviet Union continued to exist in
post-soviet Russia that of course is not
true and I think it's very important in
understanding Russian now and in
understanding the recent protests and
what will evolve from those recent
protests it's very important to
understand the nature of journalism and
the nature of dissent in Russia and I
think the easiest way to understand that
is the amount of pressure that
but come under and Russia is really goes
hand in hand with the size of the
organization so in other words in Russia
currently especially before the recent
protests there television stations which
had the widest influence were very
strictly controlled by the Kremlin you
could if you were prominent opposition
politician you were rarely if ever
allowed to appear on the state
television news there are three primary
television stations controlled by the
government and opposition figures almost
are never seen on them we were never
seen on them moving down the spectrum if
you look at radio there was one station
called echo Moskvy which regularly
featured opposition politicians
regularly feature the kind of discourse
that you might hear on NPR in the United
States or on CNN for example and that
was almost like a kind of an opposition
ghetto to some extent I think the
powers-that-be thought that was just
kind of liberals talking to liberals it
did not as well the results have that
much influence and so they largely
allowed it to exist then you move
farther down to the newspapers which
have relatively small circulations in
Russia they might have a circulation of
100,000 or 200,000 for the broadsheet
and they often could publish critical
information about the government they
could quote opposition political figures
and then you move to the internet which
is in Russia is free it's not like
people often have a misconception that
the internet in Russia is like the
internet in China that it's very
strictly controlled and that is not the
case at all there are of course I'm
talking in generalizations there are
caveats even at in at the newspapers for
example or the radio stations there were
certain subjects that throughout the
Putin era or at least the Putin era
until recently were taboo especially
official corruption the vast theft of
wealth by politicians of the states wolf
politicians even at the best newspapers
even the best investigative reporters
often were very loads
touch those and of course we know about
cases for journalists who were beaten up
or even killed in Russia because they
touched on some of those subjects but in
general you could write in a newspaper
Putin is a terrible president you could
certainly write that on the internet and
nothing what happened to you so I think
it's very important that people
understand that we have sitting in the
audience for example Gregory shred off
who's the brilliant editor of a web
publication called caucasian knot which
very closely covers the events in the
caucasus very very routinely writes
about opposition politicians very
routinely writes about people who
criticize the government now of course
they do face pressure from time to time
on the local level in the Caucasus but
at least from the state from Moscow
there I think I think there's a
relatively hands-off policy toward them
and Gregory will be on a panel later
saying you can hear him firsthand so I
just want to make give that sort of
overview of this situation currently and
I think that should perhaps help us to
understand what's going to happen from
this point one thing that's been the
most striking two people in Moscow is
how the state television covered the
first protest that occurred after the
parliamentary elections in in december i
think for journalists in moscow and even
oh those of us who just left Moscow when
we saw that opposition protests were
actually appeared on the on the
television news we practically fell out
of our chairs it was something that just
had never happened before and was to
some extent a watershed moment now
whether that's going to continue we
don't know but it is a real sign if
you're looking for markers if you're
looking to see how the political dynamic
is changing in Russia right now look
toward the television news that will
give you a real idea of almost that the
government government that the Kremlin
feels they need to let some of the
pressure off they feel that this is kind
of one concession or compromise that
they can make to the opposition to
public dissent in Russia and especially
in Moscow today so without just little
briefing I'll turn it over to Joe world
the model turned over to Joe but then
afterwards I hope we can have
good questions and answers and discuss
some of these subjects in a little more
depth Thanks yep Joe please okay let me
make 26 of comments the first has to do
with with the coverage of protest
movements in general and I'll begin in a
way with the protest movement that got
the most coverage about a decade ago
which was the Global's
anti-globalization movement that began
with the WTO protest in December 1999
that the press coverage of that i
thought was both interesting and very
good some people criticized that protest
movement and this is a general point I
want to make criticize the protest
movement for not having an agenda
without having clear objectives of
melange different people were coming
together some were concerned about
development some about the environment
some about labor rights and some of the
coverage said there's no coherent
message here but I think that really
missed the point of the protest that
they were all saying there was a common
message which was all these various
groups agreed that something was wrong
with the way globalization was being
managed and when i said the press
coverage was fairly good the response to
that was that the press looked at some
of the particular accusations that were
be made by each of these groups about
the environment about human rights about
trade about the equity and they found
that there was a lot of validity in it
and so that in a way that protest
movement I thought was very effective
because
it brought to a general consciousness an
awareness that something was wrong with
the way our political leaders were
managing the globalization process and
over the ensuing 1213 years many of the
complaints have not only been validated
but there have actually been in some
areas change less than you would have
hope but at least some areas let me just
give you a couple examples one of the
strands of the protest movement was the
anti-globalization was that the trade
agreements were unfair to developing
countries and so the eventual next round
a trade agreement nothing came out of
the Seattle meeting in in December of 2
2000 1999 but after the 911 there was a
moment of a global solidarity Mike say
and a new round of trade talks was begun
in November of 2011 and that round was
called a development or around to try to
rectify the imbalances of the previous
one in that in a sense the the protest
movement had one in early victory it was
a half victory because in ensuing 10
years nothing was done but at least the
the notion had been recognized that
previous trade agreements have been
unfair and and and so I think that was a
real victory for that protest movement
other issues that were raised were that
the global governance system was flawed
and that issue
got crystallized in a way in November of
2008 in the midst of the recession of
2008 after Lehman Brothers collapsed and
the world went from the g8 to the g20
recognizing that you could not have
global decision-making without
representatives from the emerging
markets at least the larger merging
markets and at though the series of g20
meetings there was an agreement to
change the governance of the World Bank
and IMF there was an agreement we
thought that the next leader the IMF and
the World Bank would be chosen in a
maritime meritocratic way and almost
surely not be from the United States in
Europe well the United States agreed to
it but then reneged on that agreement as
reneged on the development round
agreement and right now there's a lot of
discussion about who will be the next
head of the World Bank and whether the
United States is going to again insists
that it to be an American so but I think
the the the point I want to make is the
Proteas protest movements that that
protest movement was very successful in
bringing consciousness of a serious a
set of things that was wrong with
globalization and really has begun a
process of reform that's slow but I
think is in many ways almost surely
irreversible well the protest movements
protest movement that began with the
protests the Arab Spring the pros test
in Tunisia then Egypt and then
that moved all around the world I think
it has similarly been criticized for not
having an agenda but I think it has
succeeded in bringing to the fore an
awareness that some things are wrong and
that I think is really the function of
these protest movements I think the
press coverage in a way has not been as
quite as good as it was during the
globalization protest a decade ago and
I'll explain what I mean by that the in
the case of the the globalization
protests as I said before there were a
large number of allegations about what
was wrong with globalization and the
press looked at those allegation and out
of that there came a broad consensus
about a number of things that were wrong
and those are things that have since
been a subjects of great deal global
discussion in the case of the Arab
Spring and the protests that followed
out of that the there's not been a as
clear a discussion of why these protests
occurred at these particular countries
and what really is wrong the Reno I say
that is obviously these are protests
that are partly about lack of political
accountability lack of democracy but
there are a lot of dictatorships around
the world and the question was why did
these particular dictatorships lead to
these protests movement and my senses
there's been a lot less discussion of
trying to hone in on what why why did it
appear
these particular countries at these
particular times the grievances that
have been that that have been felt have
been long-standing and then why do they
emerge at that particular time and
thirdly the protest movement in the
United States and in Spain and in many
of the Western countries seemed in many
ways similar to some of the protests in
Arab Spring but we have democracies so
what was the issue there that that what
why was it were these protests in
democratic countries that in many ways
were similar to and inspired by the Arab
Spring so let me just very briefly
suggest a couple of the answers to these
questions and I think or perhaps they
haven't gotten as much attention in the
press they should have first I think
they're one of the reasons that the
protests have emerged in Western
democracies why kinetic stakes in Spain
is that originally there was hope that
the political system was respond to the
economic problems but they didn't and
there was a sense that of
disillusionment to a little bit not as
bad perhaps as in the caucuses but still
a sense of disillusionment at the
political system that the bankers in the
United States have brought on the crisis
and yet they were the only ones who were
doing well three-fourths of Americans
wanted more profound banking regulation
reform than we got and we sort of had a
balance between ten banks and 200
million Americans and that was an even
balance between the 10 and the 200
million so there was a sense in an
understandable sinks
that that the political system had
failed not obviously as badly as in
Tunisia or Egypt but still it had failed
secondly one of the things i think that
was not covered as a clearly say in the
case of Tunisia was it wasn't just that
there were economic problems they've
been a lot of economic problems their
economic problems of many other
countries around the world but there was
a sense that the there was something
deeply unfair about the way society and
the economy were functioning it wasn't
just that there were twenty-five
twenty-five thirty percent unemployment
or even higher among the youth but those
who got jobs were those who were
politically connected and politically
connected to a very corrupt political
system so those who work tired played by
the rules did well at school we're not
the ones getting jobs it was the ones
who had parents who were well-connected
who got the jobs and this notion of
fairness is I think a very deeply seated
notion and a lot of research in
economics that have supported the view
that this is a people feel very strongly
about fairness anybody who has children
know that they that something they care
about very very intensely and it was the
failure of the system to be fair that
really brought out the protest in
Tunisia it wasn't true in all the
countries but I think it was that
element that was very strong in the
United States as well and in the donatos
and in Spain and is they especially
after the crisis the notion that the
people only people who are doing well
were the bankers who caused the crisis
and ninety-nine percent of the rest of
the society was suffering was a real
sense of inequity next where the motto
that became Occupy Wall Street we are
the 99 percent was really set a system
statement of a gross viewing of unfair
earnest and I think the press has done a
fairly good job about covering in the
United States this sense of a fairness
but didn't look at it as much in some of
the other countries and awareness of the
extent to pay the bonus is being unfair
has been one of the the themes that have
has been picked up and the third and
final point I want to make is a common
theme in most of the protest movements
that have occurred in the last year is
that not only is there there there is
both a political and an economic problem
it's safe there we're an economic
problem the politics were able to
address it I don't think there would
have been the protest there are many
dictatorships but the dictatorships
where the economy is functioning well
you don't see protests or at least you
don't see his vocal a strong protest but
when that both of them both the
economics and the politics don't
function that's when you see these
protests and that's what happened in the
United States exploit many kept descents
in Egypt and in many of the other
countries where where there's a protest
let me just speak for a moment about
Russia and they fail the failure of the
economy as well as the politics and I I
I think would have been interesting too
I would like to see have seen a little
bit more coverage of the deep roots of
the deeper roots of the discontent going
back to back to nineteen ninety the
there was a hope
after the fall of the Soviet Union that
more democratic governments would would
arise and there was hope that of
economic reform that was meaningful in
fact things didn't work out that way and
I think this is an area where the US has
played a very important role the US
including some people who names have
been bandied for the head of the World
Bank pushed a shock therapy on Russia
the other countries in transition and
the result was not particular economic
success most people became worse off and
so the hope that this transition from a
dysfunctional political and economic
system would bring prosperity wasn't
realized and then the United States help
support a government that helped
transfer vast amounts of wealth to some
Algarve's creating inequality and a kind
of unfairness and so again we were
implicated and again I don't think
there's been enough countability for the
role that we played in that one story
that that many of you may know it is
very well known in Russia but has not
been covered very well in the United
States is the story of her the Harvard
team that was responsible for the
privatization or help me move the
privatization but in which and may it
was called the rule of law group and in
fact it was
is rife with corruption and insider
trading and and set an example for what
shouldn't be done and set an example in
a way for what market economy meant a
market economy a little bit like the
lack of moral values that we've seen in
the United States and our financial
sector so in a way there there has been
a little culpability in the case of the
United States and undermining a
democratic economic reform transition
and I'm not sure is to say that that
that has been adequately covered the
result of this is with a failure of the
reform is the creation of state
capitalism of a very peculiar kind and
one where I think they're there it's not
a I think you know 20 years it's not a
normal market economy I think we can say
say that and and it's not created the
kind of you know there are some areas
where there's some somewhat of a market
economy but the transition to a vibrant
market economy ought to be contrasted
with what's happening to China where the
the you might say that the market
economy is thriving in a more vibrant
way even though there still is a strong
element of state capitalism but they've
allowed this other side to to develop
much of us protest partly because living
standards are going up even though there
is less openness in the innocence
although interestingly and that this was
a little bit
interesting too from what cover said in
in China they have allowed the press to
attack corruption in the government and
they used the press as a way of eyes to
help the government make sure that
government isn't corrupt so they
succeeded for instance the press was a
played a very important role in bringing
down the railroad railroad minister and
now they're you know strong reporting of
corruption in that ministry and an
accounting system is going on so in a
sense what is interesting in this little
contrast is that while they have in some
sense less less free of a press they've
allowed the press to play at a role in
disciplining the political system as
long as they don't go too high so where
they draw the lines are somewhat
different and but it can be fairly
fairly strong attacks against particular
agencies particular individuals for
corruption well with that let me just
stop and great yeah I do want to make
sure that we have time to have a few
questions and answers and it while we're
preparing for those i just i wonder if
cliff and nadira have any reaction to
this idea that a successful coverage of
dissent is one that introduces some of
the the some of the main ideas at least
and the main grievances of protesters
into kind of the mainstream dialogue and
how do you achieve this when as you said
there's fundamental misunderstandings
about in the audience that you're
speaking to about what the landscape is
like in Russia thinking that it's still
like the Soviet Union or maybe not
understanding that there are big
differences between the the grievances
and the caucuses and those of the
protesters in Moscow
well I would just say a couple things
first of all I think that the role the
role of the journalism covering descent
is markedly different if you are a
domestic journalist like my fellow
panelist or if your foreign
correspondent like I was the domestic
reporters of course are part of the very
fabric of what they're covering they've
experienced it they may have come under
pressure whether it's intense pressure
or kind of a softer pressure as I have
often in Russia and so their
relationship to these topics is I think
much different than what we were writing
about them and I think a lot of the
grievances that were aired in the last
few months in Russia since the December
parliamentary elections were things that
I reported on my colleague Luke Harding
is in the back who reported for the
guardian for several years from Moscow
he reported on those topics I don't
think those issues were foreign pardon
the pun to any of our readers and I
don't think that they were formed to the
domestic audience in Russia either I
think what was striking at least in the
wake of the protest was as I mentioned
earlier how in some of the media outlets
where these subjects were taboo before
they became a little less taboo after
the protests and I think that was really
the difference when state television is
actually covering these demonstrations
in the center of Moscow and covering
them relatively objectively because of
all of us who've reported in Russia can
recall it's not like state television
completely ignored the protests in the
past what they would do would they would
be they would belittle them they would
essentially slander them it would be a
clod of kind of black PR as they refer
to it in Russia they would use against
them you'd actually have sometimes a
half an hour documentaries that would
air on some of the Russian channels that
would be essentially lengthy screeds
against the opposition protesters so
again it's not like though that
information didn't appear
television but in the wake of the
protest what we saw is relatively and I
were emphasized relatively more
objective protests on the television
about this about these events new car
service machine another ham yes deleted
another video store on a Etta in a week
in any coverage it's necessary to see
both sides at a television a promotion
ago so dostana so from the one hand it's
a government television state television
internet and the internet have some
swamp specter Society City median is a
recently in its social spectra in
Independence you know its independence
etc II watchin yer was above Nana blue
dad who officiates he taught with
Oliva dinner so sometimes it's amusing
to see how the television a particular
state television covers the events the
most evil person if you said well it's
you may not turn it on no internet East
but but there is the internet which you
can resort to yochino you bring the pain
is madre television you so many people
don't watch TV a web neurologist to
approach the potty really very Emma so
this is a waste of time on the part of
this government te weten smelly Panetti
in a chameleon okok tabu tunic are so
prioritisation Natalya's movado no
touching Utley chaser tuaca company
Molina qamishli Peru called nirvana so
in our time descent is has a different
meaning it's like some some somewhat in
a blurred it's very different from the
we review descend in the times of the
Cold War nagar sub-option messages of
racine intrude not manage to easton
economies lee it seems to me that in
verse it's very difficult to determine
it to understand what what the scent is
went our native a most in IT nukes wat
knots analyst teaches casaya doke of
Cassandra so in the internet you can
find anything from the sides of the
Nationalists to the extent Colchis
center no Dom crouppen easy media
holding de Davao had achieved tradition
and pitch at number and any canoes know
supra not lizard businessman on
plutonium cream logo naturally the
largest media holdings they belong to
the to those businessmen who are close
to the government who are associated
with the government but Yanagi ma'buta
ma'buta with you holding giornalista me
BTW has daniel buddha cheesiest any
protein is obstinate bloggy tomorrow
such as kokuzo but many journalist who
work for this media companies that
belong to private individuals they can
have their blogs and the hand can
express their opinions on the internet
no se java prosto Blass Steve litz is
cosmetic rosters esta flashy you see
Lovato's no Chile sports which internet
but the authorities you know the civil
authorities and the
enforcement below enforcement
authorities they also learned how to use
the internet it is totally private new
achieve enough to yeasty scut attack
probe last name soda pop same applies
when we blog you're a foreign channel
Chesney key for Nomo so it's very easy
to tell supervised by the a blogger
supervised by the government from the
one who is independent he would eat a
salad on a condition is a new scars and
Tucker some mr. Navarro zebras marathi
kakuta concept or no discussion so in
the one hand you know this media is a
little blurred and you know this the
concept you know that i disgust you know
you don't have certain like you know
well-defined limits to ghosts are only a
few bula-bula achieve it nuh due to non
so bully bully achieve it not blue if
your boolean a limit Ligeti puppet keep
oddly yet now subodh nakusha on the
other hand you know the attempts to
influence the free discussion of very
becoming more and more naive and more
more obvious and it's easier to fight
them welcome smoothly analog is
poisoning surveys can say is I'm adana
actually in this case the comparison
with the former Soviet Union is just one
Alou DVD at progress adopts the new pass
it to Chile vide nearly went on a teeny
version a video so people see the
pro-government position let it be TV
printed
media or elsewhere the prostate the
vidette and they don't trust it and he
should alternate even in format so and
they are seeking alternative information
thank you very much and we are running a
bit short on time since we started late
so I'd like to invite people who have
questions to step forward now to the
microphone and what I think we'll do
because we officially only have a little
more than 10 minutes if you could each
say your questions in turn and then
we'll try to have the the panelists
speak to all of them at once thank you
and also everybody should identify
themselves so I will identify myself yet
again Kathleen yamanashi and I just I
have a follow-up question to yours just
the same question away and a bit
different and it's about the role of the
press particularly in relationship to
covering descent or taken broadly I mean
the Soviet period one could argue there
was a synergistic relationship between
foreign correspondents especially
largely located in the centres in Moscow
and the dissidents um they needed the
press and they needed the Foreign Press
particularly because it was a motor
protection arm and it was way of getting
their message out and it was made of
magnifying their ability to bring change
Foreign Press needed the distance to as
a source of information and stories this
is a narrative that hasn't come up and
so far it seems to me that just to take
Occupy Wall Street since it's in the
title of the panel it's not the same
relationship but certainly even in this
age of digital media in all kinds of
different forms of communication the
Occupy Wall Street movement also needs
the press not just as a source of
information but to magnify their impact
and so is there a particular
relationship and reporting descent
between the press and dissenters in
general is something that this is
something very different from the Soviet
past or not
hello Luke Harding from the Guardian I
just wonder if the panel would stick his
neck out and tell us what it thinks
about the prospects for the protest
movement in Russia will this lead to the
demise of Vladimir Putin or will the
precious move and simply kind of fizzle
out and if if you're pessimistic as
indeed I am what makes Russia different
from say the Arab countries where there
has been a change of changing path from
a comparative perspective I mean if this
revolution isn't going to work here why
not hello my name is Tanya Sam Soliman
aradia how Moscow intro Russian
journalists and my question is what when
in democratic countries people protest
against banks bankers and unfairness of
banking system it resembles the protests
in Russia when people protest against
putting an a fairness of election all
system and in both situations people
clearly understand that their mission is
impossible still they do this they do so
and what how can they really affect the
system because everybody knows then you
can't ruin back so you can ruin bankers
you can't really put him for for now and
the outcome of more free press in Russia
isn't a good answer for those who really
came to the streets to protest that
attitude to make him not to win the
presidential elections so how can these
movements affect the situation Thanks
one more question it's either focus on
value from media scholar from on going
to China just 212 supplemented professor
stiglitz about Chinese present out to
attack the corruption in effect actually
this is the very tricky questions
because Chinese pressing control the
manager even more seriously by the state
the so-called allowing attack the
corruption is actually partially related
to the power struggle internal of the
party leadership but as you
mention that you know real way you know
kind of a corruption is one particular
school of the party 12 you know dong and
that the other side is so allowed the
press to do such things other than that
I don't feel Chinese press impressive
freedom has any progress in the last 10
years thank you so let's jump right into
responding to the questions to recap we
had a question about the relationship
between the press and dissenters the
future of Russia and Putin and how can
protest be effective and how can they
measure their success so anyone who'd
like to jump in can I mean I guess I can
I'll take on the first question in truth
I don't think the relationship between
dissidents and foreign correspondents in
the Soviet Union is that different than
the relationship between reporters in
Moscow today and the opposition
movements or reporters in New York and
the Occupy Wall Street protesters the
fact is is that all reporters have
symbiotic relationships with their
sources they want the information the
sources want the publicity again it's a
little bit of a generalization there's
of course there's a lot of nuances here
a lot of the dissidents and the Soviet
Union we're doing something very risky
by contacting foreign correspondence we
know that and certainly the Occupy Wall
Street protesters are not going to get
into that kind of trouble by talking to
reporters but having said that I think
the dynamic is relatively similar I do
think that in Moscow today if you look
at Navalny for example who is the
prominent blogger or if you look at
guinea takova who is a prominent
environmental activist she in particular
has sought out Western journalists and
Russian journals very actively because
she wants to get her story out because
it kind of empowers her it empowers her
movement it's it's an enormous
amplification especially when you are
shut out as she has been from the
mainstream Russian meteor certainly the
Russian TV in the Russian radio and I
don't think that's any different than a
dissonant in 1973 in Brezhnev era
Union so I want to emphasize I am
drawing a little bit of a broad brush
here but I do think that reporters want
to use their sources and their sources
want to use reporters and it has been it
is and it always will be yeah let me
just make a couple comments one of them
is this distinction between providing
information and mobilizing and there's
always the hope of on the part of say
dissidents that if only people knew that
would mobilize them and I think that's
not true I I think that that's why you
know people in the political parties
work very hard to figure out what their
message is even to the point where they
you know they they test various ways of
saying the same thing and get to figure
out what the response of the listener is
you can say the same sentence but put
the adjectives in three different ways
and it has different emotive responses
advertising agencies of course do this
as well and next is related to in a way
why the internet is not a very may not
be a very effective way of mobilizing
because the Internet has different
communities and the only people
listening are the people who are already
converted it's not quite true but but to
a large extent you have these separate
communities on the internet where if you
the people who already believe that
there needs to be changed our reading
the internet sites and the others aren't
seeing it and this is a real concern
about the internet and its ability to to
to mobilize I mean there are instances
where where it has been able to to
do the mobilization that's why in a way
there's a little bit of a randomness to
whether the protest movements are
successful as I say I don't think the
the protest movements in the
globalization that I talked about in
1999 they didn't have a press officer
who was trying to figure out what was
the message they ought to get across and
how to articulate it it just if they had
a number of messages and the press
picked up looked at some of the things
and they really were sufficiently
salient that that it worked I think the
same thing is true about the Occupy Wall
Street but I think they were lucky they
picked on a couple of issues that were
really really resonated and the two were
the bankers bonuses and the we are the
ninety-nine percent and those were
really they couldn't have been much
better if they have I call it a media
company and said how do we you know how
do we get our messages across I mean
those were two very powerful very
powerful messages and I think that that
work but this is a real problem I think
with with protest movements because
they're organic they're not they're not
run by a press office and sometimes they
get messages that succeed and sometimes
they don't and I I think part of the job
of the press I think is to try to figure
out what they ought if they did have a
press office what would they be doing
and how would they put it because
they're there they really are their
intent is not just to give information
it really is to mobilize the there is a
sense and I there is a sense in which
most of the protesters probably don't
really think that are going to succeed
you know the reason you're protesting is
that you see the system not working
and do you really believe that goodbye
going out in the street and shouting a
little bit you're going to change really
realpolitik the real forces that are
play I think that most people don't
really think that but there was always a
glimmer of hope that you will and there
are always a few of those cases where
well where it has happened Tunisia
seemed to really work in the way that
people wanted issue whether Egypt is
working the way people want it is really
much less clear and the same thing is
through is true about Russia I think
that but even when it doesn't fully
accomplished what you want and go back
to the globalization it does change mine
sex Occupy Wall Street I think the
ninety-nine percent that backs now
become part of the as really resonated
it have affected some of the speeches of
President Obama and will I think affect
the elections I mean I think it will it
will tarnish one of the candidates if he
if he if it's one of those one percent
that gets elected who doesn't pay taxes
it will be a much more difficult for him
to run his campaign given the Occupy
Wall Street so there is the things that
you know high chance that won't work but
even if it has a little bit effect it's
worth the pushing thank you Jeff we're
officially over time but I hope we can
take just a couple minutes to finish
sharing some responses yanis on deal
about new frozen analyst which i think i
will just you know say one nikka
histology me to the hiroshi up with the
sky some tacky prom of key Mozgov brush
leach it is colorful because many people
in various country went through this you
know horrible experience of brainwashing
it's just la jeunesse lodge near house
Kotaku's becoming more and more
difficult overreaction
Aetna's money that it's na say keep up
with kiss me strivers of kakuta sis TMO
bar boys Anika Muslim so any attempts
attempts of the mass media to something
like to incorporate the efforts in the
struggle against descent some developed
prostate discredited at us me discredit
the mass media e tanto is done is done
on smoochy media prostitutes voy so you
would credit nest so that's there so
this part of the mass media just loses
its credibility absolutely horrible
nutrition subjects and auditoria blood
that was okay volatility of liquid
Monsieur bizarre so the the reader is
and the viewers the minimal volatile we
know of liquid absolutely soaked a
concurrency media does to place to me in
this hero very high got the word
negativeness something different you
know representatives of mass media
sedation 80 sivaprasad limit our names
cosmetic legit as possible st what we
meet Aniyah die vehicles me so it is the
question of trust at all so bascially
bugs me the woodburner management that
is the the choice of the people of
reviewers and readers and those managers
who run different you know units of mass
media well thank you so much I regret
that we're out of time because I feel
like we've just tipped the touched the
tip of the iceberg with a lot of these
issues but I hope that it got the
thought juices flowing and I would like
to extend a huge thank you to our
panelists for taking time to speak with
us today was a pleasure
you